[MYSTERIOUS MUSIC]
I'm sorry I hurt you.
For Jericho, there is
nothing I wouldn't do, nothing.
He's part of me.
Do you understand?
You can lock me in now.
Lisa Brühlmann, who directed
in the first season as well,
directed this episode.
You scared me, what you did.
I know, harming her.
I know I went way too far.
She has great, great instincts.
And she has a kind of
intimacy of performance,
but a very different,
off-kilter point of view.
And I want to celebrate that.
You don't give them the bag,
until they hand over the baby.
And you don't let
her out of your sight.
Go get him.
You know, this season, season two,
I think the two female
characters are really
where the action is for us.
So having female directors
come in and defend them
in the right way was a
powerful thing for our show.
It's called a King Cake.
My mother used to make it on Sundays.
She taught me how.
This episode's also about
Leanne's history and her mother
and a lot of Leanne's
behavior is tied to that.
She said whoever was most
special would get the baby.
We get to learn a little
bit about what happened to her.
And who is this mother?
And maybe she didn't have the best mother.
She always found the baby.
She would hold it up in her
hand for me to see it.
And then, she'd make me say it.
You're the special one!
She's reliving it and
changing the ending of it,
becoming very powerful and
using her anger, saying,
I'm no longer going to be the victim.